hi there uh this is steve kaufman i'm
replying to this uh
wonderful uh youtube that's been put up
uh making people aware of all the
resources that are there for language
learning
i speak nine languages i'm actually
fairly far along in my tenth which is
russian
we effective
hablo espanol tambien um
now i'm getting confused but i do a
little bit of korean
uh
anyway just to say that i've learned
quite a few languages
the um uh
reason the internet is a phenomenal
place to learn languages but
in learning these 10 languages
i don't do the kinds of things that fsi
and live mocha
and mango offer you
i don't do exercises and and lessons
lesson one two three four five i don't
do grammar i don't do drills
i don't do theories
language learning to me is a matter of
listening and reading starting with
short
relatively easy content and gradually
working your way to more difficult
content always focusing on
absorbing the language and gradually
getting used to the language now
fortunately on the internet there are
many resources for the independent
learner and the key thing in language
learning is to become an independent
learner so you don't want to rely on a
teacher or a classroom or lesson one
lesson two lesson three you wanna go and
find things that interest you in the
language that are more or less at your
level and just do a lot of listening if
you're stumped it's easy enough to go to
google
and look up the phrase translator or go
you know verbs spanish verbs french
verbs there's just so much help there
and
what i have done because of my interest
in language learning and i'll put this
right up front
i have a website called link
lingq.com where we have a great variety
of content mp3 and
transcript text all of which is free and
people can go there they can download
the audio
uh the
audio is divided into beginner and easy
and then more difficult
and the system helps you learn words
helps you save words that you don't
understand so that you can use
flashcards and then the system gets to
know which words you know so it can
direct you to content that is more or
less at your level
uh you can make use of all the resources
on the internet because the system
allows you to
in addition to what we have in our
library it allows you to import content
from any any site you find you can
import the sound file the text file and
you can work with it within link just
the same way so i mean i just wanted to
get a plug-in obviously for link when
we're talking about resources on the web
i believe that our community
our methodology
is ideal for the web in fact we are a
web 2.0 application because we're
getting our learners
to give us content in their own
languages so that people who are
studying english and who are native
speakers of french or spanish or
japanese are creating very interesting
content with transcript uh that people
can learn from we are a
newcomer we are growing we are
developing uh more and more
functionality all the time so i just i
hope this is appropriate maybe i'll get
zapped wanted to put a plug in for link
lingq.com
i hope to see some of you there
and now i got to put my glasses on so i
can shut down this video here
bye for now